these cartoonists its journalists these
policemen it's a simple employee these
simple citizens of the Jewish faith
died because they defended
criticism humor satire freedom
of expression I ask you dear
colleagues to stand up for a minute
of  silence in memory of the victims
the commission all lived but
such was its initial desire to
present to the council by June
a package of measures in the fight
against tax evasion
you say the confidence of the markets has
returned
I would like to ask you a question
Are we elected here to satisfy the
markets Wouldn't it be interesting to
ask ourselves the question of the
silly trust of our fellow citizens This we have to
super matches action for peace
respects absences we sso respects a
first movie drive security news
fight terrorism signals
president means that in who carey will be told
the cases where these deep
channels door in doha  the week in tchita
ok you hear me well
what are in your opinion the limits
of freedom of expression
inside the european parliament you
know that what a deputy expresses in
parliament is not subject to
cronyism we  enemies are not in
moscow they are in mosques that's
what he said
those two views let
me tell the mayor said honestly
from a content point of view more of a
case for our medical service  this in
january will remain the date of birth
of europe peoples united in
diversity united in adversity
we must also recognize a failure
these terrorists are our children born on
our soil he rose on our soil dead
on our soil did he  said